the number one need they had was housing
they said sort of none of these
great cultural ideas matter if we don't
have anywhere to live
followed quickly by we don't have strong
broadband followed by child care
followed by transportation medical
services etc
quality of life amenities are right in
there with the need
but that's the thing with rural is they
don't have the luxury of focusing on one
of these issues over another they have
to tackle all of them at the same time
welcome to 20-minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctek
let's talk about 3d printing meet
zachary mannheimer
founder and ceo of alquist a 3d printing
construction company
that uses cutting-edge technology to
create houses buildings and other
structures aimed at dropping the cost of
homes
and solving the housing crisis after a
road trip from new york city to 22
cities around the country
zachary chosen settled in des moines in
founding the des moines social club an
arts and educational nonprofit
in 11 years of operations dmsc hosted
over 10 000 events for over 1 million
patrons
in 2020 zachary co-founded atlas
community studios
a team helping rural communities plan
for growth in over 20 states
where the main concern is housing he
lives in iowa city with his wife sarah
and their three kids meera
benjamin and fiona meet zachary zachary
manheimer
welcome to 20 minute leaders how are you
today
i'm well thanks for having me i'm
excited to talk about from running off
broadway
theater in new york to printing
3d construction homes it's going to be a
wild journey for us in the next 20
minutes but first where are we calling
from right now
i'm in at home in iowa city iowa
and so i believe that out of i think
this is episode 400 and something you
are
the first person that i have from iowa
which makes me very excited but i think
you're the second or third person that
is working on 3d home construction which
is
you know something that i've gotten
pretty passionate about myself so i'm
excited for this conversation
but but you have to take me back first
to your job as
running off broadway theaters my brother
is a broadway
musical director and so it's a very very
close to my heart as well
but i'd love to hear where you're coming
from
oh that's terrific uh so yeah the i was
a
a theater and philosophy major in
college so when i graduated i had
absolutely zero job prospects
uh i moved to london i lived in
in london for about two years uh doing
theater over there
and then my visa expired and i had to
come back to the states and i did what
every other new york
theater major or any other theater major
does in america we went to new york
uh so and my family originally grew up
outside philadelphia i'm from the east
coast my family's
grew up in in new york city so i was
very familiar with it
uh so i lived in brooklyn for almost 10
years
uh and i i i wish i was doing
off-broadway i was doing off
off-broadway
um so way way off um i started a company
there called uh the subjective theater
company
uh that ran for a little over 10 years
and we did
uh very avant-garde experimental shows
all around new york city i worked with
the new york fringe festival for a while
um
and and it was great and it had a really
wonderful sense of community but
you know what we found there was that
the shows that we were producing at the
time
uh were fairly political in nature
and the people around me in brooklyn
everybody kind of thought like me
acted like me played like me ate like me
and i didn't feel that it was very
healthy to be living in a bubble
uh either as an artist or as a human
and i i wanted to go off and see the
rest of the country so that's
that's where that came from and so uh
you know
a lot of people say they want to say the
rest of the country but but not many
people
get into a car and visit where is it 22
cities in a road trip
22 cities yes that was uh the summer of
i went to 22. and what was the purpose
of that so why
what what i i understand you're talking
you know you want to get exposed to okay
what's actually happening you know in
this country
was there a was there a mission did you
know you know what you were trying to
achieve
at the end of this road trip yeah i mean
i what it became was very different than
what i
uh was originally thinking it was much
better but the original idea was i was
searching for the new the next place i
wanted to live
i wanted a community that was roughly
half a million people in the metro
which you know compared to new york city
is small i wanted a city that
was more like a third city i wanted a
city that had
struggled to retain and in
the next generation workforce i wanted a
city that needed some revitalization in
the downtown
uh and i wanted one that had an art
scene that was burgeoning but not
established nationally and something
that was as close to 50 50 politically
as i could find and so des moines
checked all my boxes
and so you're in des moines iowa and so
you and from that point on
you diverge quite a bit from theater and
why so why why not stay in theater even
though you're
transitioning to a place that perhaps is
less of a of a bubble like nature
well we i still was doing theater i was
directing theater uh
quite a bit when i first moved there but
over time that dropped away because my
responsibility shifted for what we
wanted to do
uh so myself and many other people
got together and we formed a nonprofit
that became the des moines social club
that was a space in downtown des moines
that
produced thousands of different events
in every single
arts of related medium we wanted a real
sense of community of
of different people different ideologies
different backgrounds different
demographics coming together and so
that's why we wanted to
see how many different artistic mediums
could we hit so there was at least
something for everybody at least once a
month
and i was still directing shows but over
time that peeled away
in terms of uh responsibilities to
run the nonprofit to work with all sorts
of different people around town and
it became something that was much larger
than just an arts-based organization
it was trying to build community in the
space
right so i'm hearing this is where the
the social aspects are starting to sink
in right when you're actually
you know you're you're you're starting
to bridge from the world of of arts and
and what you did enough off broadway but
now you're actually understanding okay
well there's actually a
pretty big social impact that is being
done and and
i guess from that point on you just
continue to expand on that
and and concentrate on that right yeah
it kept growing
and uh as it as it uh kept getting
bigger and getting successful
uh and getting established in the place
that we were and you know this took
several years
we started getting calls from other
smaller communities more rural
mostly around iowa that wanted to do
something similar and they saw this as a
viable option for
how to revitalize a community and help
from an economic model uh population
model etc and so we started traveling to
some small communities and i'm
my original uh town i grew up in was
rural
uh when i was born but by the time i
graduated high school it ceased to be
rural
it became suburban it got sucked into
the philadelphia metro and i i really
never wanted to see that happen again to
any other community
and so we began traveling to these rural
communities and i developed a true
passion for it
and it's through that work that we
developed our creative place making
model that eventually became
uh the my other organization which is
called atlas
and so so we're in 2020
and you you then start to focus your
work on on rural communities but not
just
you know you know at one point you can
imagine
a person working with a rural community
coming and volunteering and doing some
hands-on work with charity and
and etc but but you're actually thinking
of a different approach and you're
actually looking at this more
strategically
with atlas community studios and you're
actually planning growth for
in over you know 20 states what does
that mean
you know to plan for growth especially
in the world of housing
especially as you as you do it through
you know more than almost two dozen
communities
yeah we wanted to we originally were
going to these communities to help them
with revitalization outputs mostly on a
cultural scale
how can we help them with public murals
uh with
fixing up storefronts and possibly
creating coffee shops cultural centers
et cetera
but we began to and that was our
background but we began to hear the
uh things like you know we really need
child care child care is essential
uh medical services our hospital left
you know years ago and these are towns
averaging around 3
000 people and then they said of course
the number one need they had
was housing they said sort of none of
these great cultural ideas matter
if we don't have anywhere to live
followed quickly by we don't have strong
broadband followed by child care
followed by transportation medical
services etc
quality of life amenities are right in
there with the need
but that's the thing with rural is they
don't have the luxury of focusing on one
of these issues over another they have
to tackle all of them at the same time
and so that's how we fell into housing
and we're traveling to these towns in
20 uh 20 more 20 states and more
over the several years and the need in
rural mississippi is the same need in
rural minnesota
it's identical in terms of housing that
they need there
and so we were being challenged and
asked all the time to try to figure out
a solution to the rural housing crisis
and uh you know folks have been trying
to do this for decades
and right around 2016ish
i was and i was remembering this i got
asked to go to a
an event featuring a futurist um where
there was a guy coming who said he was a
futurist i never knew what that meant
uh but you know sounded interesting so i
went to this talk
and he was talking about all sorts of
things that were going to happen
uh over the next 20 30 years and one of
them was 3d printing technology of
printing buildings and i had never heard
of that before
and he's showing all these videos of it
happening it's blowing my mind and
somebody in the audience
asked hey how long until you think this
is the norm
for the construction industry worldwide
and he's thought about he said well
probably 10 to 15 years
it's going to take that long because of
zoning and unions and regulation and all
sorts of things you got to work through
and so that seemed to make sense
everybody in the room kind of agreed
with it
but afterwards i went up to him i bought
a copy of his book his name is thomas
frey
and i asked him i said hey so i agree
with you about what you were saying for
urban areas
but for rural communities a lot of the
barriers and hurdles that you see
may not be true is do you think that we
could start 3d printing in rural
faster than urban he thought about and
he said yeah i
i never considered that i kind of think
you're right and so that started off
uh several conversations i had with him
on email we met for dinner in omaha once
and just talking about it he kind of
coached me through some of these ideas
and that was all i needed then i was off
and running doing tons of research on
the technology how to make it happen and
uh
that's how we arrived where we are today
so
so take me back a little bit to to rural
areas and housing
is it simply a matter of there are not
enough houses to house
all the people that need housing or is
it that the infrastructure of the houses
is bad what what is actually the the
pain point
that that you're looking at so it's all
the above and it kind of comes back to
you know wanting to build community and
that's always my goal uh
what we what we see here in rural
communities there's
plenty of homes typically less that are
100 000
or less but most of those need
significant uh fixing up and not
everybody's willing to do that
and there's sometimes homes in the 250
to 300 000 and more
but that price is out normally 60 70 of
the market there
it's that middle ground where we're not
seeing the homes being built or
uh the other concern is that you've got
people aging in place
that uh they need to move on to a
smaller unit
and giving up that home to put it back
on the market that's something else that
we're seeing across the board
senior housing etc so that's the need in
all of these places and the bottom line
is the cost of build doesn't equal the
cost to sell
and there's this myth in rural america
that there's no good paying jobs and
that's
completely a myth there's thousands of
good paying jobs in the world there's
simply not enough people to take the
jobs
and that was true before covid but covid
has really changed
everything uh we used to see people
migrating from
first cities to second cities now we're
seeing people migrating from first
cities to fifth cities
and that's a major shift and right now
we see
a huge opportunity for rural america to
grab it
and build the housing that's needed or
they're going to miss the boat
and so without quest 3d did i say the
correct alquest
calquest yes where does that name come
from first of all you're
talking about 3d printing without
construction tech and housing but
what what does alquist mean so al quest
is goes back to my theater background
it's super obscure
uh there was a play maybe not that
obscure there's a play that was written
in 1919 called r-u-r which stands for
rossum's universal robots it's by a
czechoslovakian
writer named carl chopik who i love um
rur was the first play
first piece of literature ever to coin
the term robot
that's where robot comes from and it was
the first piece of literature that
was the age-old sci-fi uh plot where
robots
are created they learn they decide they
don't like their surroundings and they
try to take over and kill humanity
and uh you know that's basically the
part of the show um but there's one
character the main engineer
in the play whose name is alquist he's
the only person in the show
that believes that robots and humans can
coexist peacefully
so that's where the name comes from i
love it okay so now
more strategically about al quest and
how you're you're you're meeting
you're meeting in omaha for dinner and
you're saying okay this is actually
a viable solution i mean we can actually
improve
you know cities and 20 in you know
multiple states across the united states
by leveraging this technology from that
what do you do then how do you actually
get started from that point on
so the we've got a list of well over
100 communities that would like us to
come and build yesterday if we had the
uh ability to do it we're ramping up
right now we're you know obviously in
our startup phase
uh we were established late last year so
it's still the beginning
uh we're in the process of doing our
first home right now in richmond
virginia and this is where things
shifted for us was that
we were fortunate enough to become
acquainted with dr andrew mccoy who
runs the housing department uh at
virginia tech university
and they have been studying this for a
long time and the state of virginia
offered a grant
uh to folks who wanted to come and
experiment and see if 3d can really be
unanswered uh for the future so
uh alquist and virginia tech
collaborated to get the grant we're
working together right now
to build the first 3d home that will be
uh
built for residential sale at an
affordable level
in america this is also the first one
that's going to have public funds
that are helping build it uh it's gonna
be built in richmond
uh virginia uh we're gonna do the print
the end of uh
this month and then the home will be
constructed over the next couple weeks
with the rest of the build out
but the print time will be super fast um
the first one
it's going to be about a week for the
print um for a 1500 square foot home
uh we believe by the second or third
print we'll probably be able to get that
time down to two or three days
so walk me through the supply chain from
the moment that you have a plot of land
that you want to build on to the moment
where a family can actually go in there
and
go to sleep at night and cook dinner and
how how does the supply chain actually
look from start to finish
so first first step is acquiring the
land um and this is why our focus is
rural richmond obviously is not rural
uh that's where the folks with the grant
wanted us to produce the home that's
fine
um every other community that we do this
year and next year will likely be rural
um the uh so acquiring the land is
number one
and in many commun many rural
communities there's lots of land to be
acquired
uh but then you need the infrastructure
that the community might need to help
out with which is terms of running you
know utilities electrical etc
so first we acquired the land there's
lots of ways to do that uh then we
designed the home so we have one design
currently it's sort of a modern
farmhouse we wanted to
do something that was approachable uh
when people think of a 3d home they
think of futuristic things and it kind
of blows people's minds and
we wanted something that looks very much
like a traditional
home that people have uh we have lots of
other designs that get crazier and we'll
be on
uh revealing those later this year so
somebody would choose which home which
style of home they want from us
we'll work with them to customize it and
that's the beauty of 3d is that we can
really customize this quickly
once we all desi decide on a design
we bring in our engineers and the rest
of the team and our uh technicians
and we do that we print the base of the
home so you think of it this way that a
concrete 3d home is just like any other
home except the walls are made out of
concrete instead of wood
that's the only difference otherwise
it's almost identical
so the print time can take two to three
days
uh then we bring in the electricians the
plumbers the hvac unit the roofers uh
there are some cases we'll
we will be printing the roof the first
few homes we will not be
um we're taking it slow but uh
the goal is to be able to have a brand
new home from start to finish from when
the print starts to when
families can move in in about three and
a half months
that that's the that's what we're
shooting for these first couple homes
will take a little bit longer
uh but by next year that's that's where
we want to be
unbelievable and i can you know
obviously i don't think that anybody
has any doubt that this is this is
completely the future and then i think
it's a good question whether it's in
five years or whether it's in 15 years
but i personally get excited just
hearing that
somebody in in you know in iowa right
now is sitting and is going to be
printing a home in richmond virginia
and is already thinking about the scale
of it and how to do it in a startup
phase and it's not just
a and you know it's not a it's not an
experiment it's actually
family is going to be living in this
home and that's i think you know to me
one of the most exciting aspects and i
really
i really want to thank you for coming
here and i have a few questions for you
before we finish if you're ready for
them absolutely
okay they're not connected to homes but
they're connected to you
what is one of your favorite subjects
from middle school or
high school uh you know
my the the subject that changed my life
in high school was i got to be part of a
creative writing program
uh and there was a teacher there named
uh
miss fox who inspired me and uh many
other people i know
to really think creatively think outside
the box and
really to become an optimist to see the
world
in a positive way that just because you
have an idea and there's challenges to
making that idea a reality
doesn't mean it can't happen it means it
can happen and you have to pursue it
and it's it sounds like you need a lot
of optimism and you need a lot of
out-of-the-box thinking
and creativity to do what you're doing
today so that makes a lot of sense
and who would be one of your role models
or somebody that that inspires you in
one way or another
oh there's there's lots of people um i
go back to
joe papp who studied post uh started the
public theater in new york and
really fostered the sense of community
uh
uh jack kerouac and what he was able to
create
and inspire folks to get to the next
level um
people that uh i'm reading now that
are really taking things to the new
level there was a great
uh book came at a a year or two ago
um by steve case uh third wave that
talks about where things are going to be
moving um
you know i i'm trying to read all the
time
and expand on ideas and there's just
there's so many
out there so those are those are top of
mind today but if you ask me tomorrow
that could be different
of course and what are three words that
you would use to describe yourself
uh driven um
excitable and uh i would say
uh circus-like creative um
always trying to see what's next what's
fun how do we bring people together
and i'll definitely add optimist to the
list if you if you'll allow me
but zachary thank you very much for your
time this was wonderful thank you for
making honestly you know
both people's lives better but the world
eventually better and you know
regardless of what happens without quest
3d just you know the the inertia that is
being created here
and the the the way that this is being
shown to the world i think is going to
you know have
a tremendous ripple effect not just in
the in the 3d housing but but in
everything that we think about in the
day-to-day that we say it was being done
in one way
for the for thousands of years really
and today we can actually we can
actually
do things differently and i think that's
going to be very exciting so thank you
very much zachary
thank you the housing industry is
overdue for disruption so this will be
fun
take care bye